yes exactly I have Fabiano Carana here
with me the game with Nish giri finished
in a draw we haven't even finished our
coffee yet what happened in this game
Bobby yeah so I had this thought
yesterday that maybe he doesn't really
want to win the game mhm just because
the candidates race is so weird that of
course he doesn't want like Wesley to
get a higher ranking in this tournament
because that would give Wesley the
better circuit tour this is basically
the explanation for what happened today
and actually I kind of I know Anish is
like um he's kind of a master of like
body language so when he already played
his like first four moves he was playing
them so quickly that I had this
impression that he he wants to draw like
both the opening choice and the speed at
which he was moving it felt like kind of
body language like let's finish this
game so I was kind of thinking like okay
what to do I decided to play C6 line now
you have to find a way to make a draw
yes with black pieces also no no I mean
I I of course like DC4 is the line I
usually Play It's of course extremely
solid but this is more of a fighting
line in fact the thing is that after
like Rook D1 Knight D7 Knight E5 uh
black doesn't really have ways to to
continue the game because you shouldn't
I mean if you take on E5 you get a bit
worse mhm like there's this kind of I
think well-known line something like
this um and other moves I mean there are
moves here like I think you can play
Rook C8 you can play H6 you can do
various moves but kind of the the proved
way is to do this and then you repeat
moves actually I in this position I
think many years ago I was playing this
position with white pieces a few times
for example I played it against deer and
N pianu I played it against Mickey Adams
um it's a very complicated fight with
two Bishops and black is solid but I
kind of understood that he's of course
not going for this he's going for the
repetition and so for my tournament
situation it's a really good result also
with black pieces today yeah it's a f
result is it is it a little bit strange
know that he really with white pieces
it's better for him to make a draw yes I
mean so how it sounds really know it's
of course this fed qualific uh canas
qualification is makes things really
weird um I he even said after the game
like I could have tried to bully him and
uh like let's say gone all out for a win
and then he he's in a weird situation
like maybe he doesn't even want to win
if I do something wrong but of course I
I don't know his intentions like maybe
he he still wants to win and uh so I
anyway I decided to approach the game
like any game where if I'm playing with
the black pieces uh I'm not I wasn't
thinking so much about his situation
like I need to exploit it but if I'm
playing with the black pieces against
top level player then draw I can't
complain exactly and did he say
something after the game yeah we were
discussing um few of us were discussing
like candidates because of course laner
has has a chance it's very interesting
as well other players also have a chance
I mean Wesley clearly has a chance by
rating now uh gash for example Ari even
has an outside chance chance I think
Arjun I was calculating some
possibilities that Arjun could have a
very good final stretch and maybe
qualify and even by rating spot maybe
param makulu has a chance W so there's
uh and in some kind of maybe bizarre
world where like Vincent kimer wins all
his games for the rest of the year even
he could have a chance so it's it's
really a tight race there's a lot of
people potentially with a shot
absolutely but of course let's not
forget that yesterday anybody in this
tournament lost him theoretical chance
to catch up with you for the grand chest
points and you won the grandest two
rounds to spare congratulations fa on
that and also former world champion Gary
Kasparov sent the Tweet the tremendous
result and so what do you think about it
it's really hard actually to start
celebrating when you play the tournament
still but how do you approach yeah no
now it's of course a new goal uh to try
to win the tournament it's I have a good
chance ler also has a good chance and I
think nobody else has a very realistic
chance I believe I mean of course things
could happen but probably Wesley will
make a draw today Wesley yeah Wesley
drew it drew yes it was clear for him
that uh like he's trying to take his
chance with the rating spot maybe and he
still has a good chance with the rating
spot after this draw so um Wesley
doesn't have any more games so he's he
uh finish the tournament he can't win
the tournament I mean he can only tie
for first if both of us lose and laner
draws here and loses his last game or
something like that then it would be a
tie but um but generally speaking uh
most likely one of us will uh either
share first or um or get clear first you
you play with Richard tomorrow with
white pieces what do you think about it
yeah it's Richard doesn't have so such a
good event so far yeah he's he's
struggling here uh a lot depends on this
game of course of of lenier because
we'll see how the tournament situation
looks he could win this game but uh I
feel like Maxim has has prepared some
very sharp stuff it's clear he's in
preparation he doesn't normally play
snov so he played this um rare move here
Knight to E7 this is actually favorite I
think used to be of Magnus Carlson and
to be honest a long time ago I checked
this position but it's really been a
long time and I don't remember a single
thing about it so F6 uh and Knight F5
and we'll see what happens because it's
super sharp yeah very interesting game I
don't think lener will lose because he's
such a stable player and and um and
generally speaking unless you unless
something goes wrong white should be in
complete safety here um but the moment
it doesn't look like that D is yeah it's
super sharp of course it's good for
maxim that he's in preparation because
if he warer in preparation I would
assume that black would be in serious
danger of course yeah thank you so much
Fab and all the best of luck for you for
the last round and see you tomorrow
thank you thank you thank you Anastasia
thank you Fabby and let's just refresh
everyone's memory about the fabulous
year that Fab's had yeah it has indeed
been fantastic it started in Romania
winning the competition there and
earning
$100,000 and the grand chest Croatia
came fourth knitted 20,000 and then at
the World Cup in August he secured his
spot to the 2024 candidates by netting
third place also US champion and just
recently won the St Louis rapid and
Blitz and also 2023 Grand chess tour
champion and maybe still the SNF Cup
champion as well that would mean that he
would be a double winner of the two
classical events in the grand chest